and they live with the real life
consequences of our Wars every day I bet
it's something you know you really
haven't thought about because we haven't
been in a war in a few years and so it's
not in the fall
oh I'm Dave Rubin this is the Reuben
report it is September 12
2022 we are live streaming on Rumble
YouTube and blazetv don't forget to
subscribe tap the notification Bell
share let your friends and family know
that you watch this hardcore right-wing
internet video show do that for me would
you our cold open today of course that
was Dr Jill Biden you always have to
refer to her as Dr Jill Biden she of
course who Whoopi Goldberg wanted to be
the head of the CDC although she is not
a doctor of medicine
whoops whoopee actually put the whoops
in Whoopi
um she there saying that we haven't been
any wars in a couple years uh I don't
know why we keep giving Ukraine 80
million a pop every 80 billion above 80
million that would be something 80
billion a pop every now and again uh we
also had a disastrous withdrawal of
Afghanistan under her husband and a
whole bunch more but that's what they do
they just lie Ai and obfuscate and all
that stuff I just thought that was an
interesting way to start the show but
that's not what we're focused on today
uh today first off it is the birthday
the 44th birthday of Florida Governor
Ron DeSantis so happy birthday Governor
thank you for keeping this state free
thank you for welcoming refugees as I
look at my Refugee employees right in
front of me all happier healthier and
more tan than when they were in
California and oh and I should say I'm
feeling very good about life today I got
a fresh haircut yesterday I'm feeling
good about the tight sides and I played
full court basketball last night for the
first time in seven years got a knee
brace buckled in and I played extremely
well so life is good over here so what
we're going to focus on since it is the
governor's birthday is a New York Times
silly a silly ridiculous nonsensical hit
piece that the New York Times put out
yesterday
and it's just like an endless Litany of
nonsense but the reason I want to show
it to you is really to show you more I
know you guys understand generally
speaking how the media manipulates and
lies and you know changes meaning
depending on who they're writing about
whether they like the person or not but
they put out this little Twitter Thread
about the article and the framing is so
backwards and confusing that you can see
why so many people that read their paper
are stupid so that's what we're going to
be getting to I think we should show the
the DeSantis my my favorite moment with
the gov first uh since we're doing this
show dedicating it to the governor on
his birthday here's a a classic moment
with Governor Ron DeSantis all right so
first off we have to start with the
obvious one
gay
[Applause]
he didn't even flinch
he's a good dude he does not care
whether you're gay or not and he wants
all people to be treated equally he just
doesn't want kids learning about sex and
gender Theory from government employees
and hiding it from parents how radical
how radical indeed okay before we get to
any of that let me talk to you guys
about Cozy Earth and then we'll get to
it you know hotter weather used to mean
goodbye to a good night's sleep until I
discovered cozy Earth cozy Earth's
bedding is so soft luxurious and
temperature regulating I'm sleeping
better than I have in years listen
there's a good reason why cozy Earth has
over a thousand has thousands over
thousands of five star reviews at
cozyearth.com it's truly awesome betting
here's one from Laura we literally just
got them put on our new bed yesterday
and guys they are incredible these
sheets are worth every penny cozy Earth
sheets made from a hundred percent
viscous from bamboo are now available in
four natural colors and don't forget
their temperature regulating and very
breathable so you'll sleep cool and
comfy year round for a limited time save
35 percent on cozy Earth betting be sure
to check out their Ultra Soft loungewear
too I love the sweatpants even here in
Florida that's how cool they are go to
cozyearth.com Dave and save 35 now all
back by 100 night sleep guarantee
cozyearth.com Dave for 35
off okay so the New York Times writes a
piece about Ron DeSantis and and let's
show the first image here uh this is
that's what the cover of the New York
Times magazine is and obviously you can
have you have Ron desantis's smiling
face covering up Donald Trump so what
they're trying to do just by the very
nature of the piece what they because
they know that a picture is worth a
thousand words what they really want to
do with this thing is drive a wedge
between the santis and Trump so the the
headline that they had with that in the
Tweet was is Ron DeSantis the Republican
party's future in New York Magazine Matt
Flagg whatever his name is conducts an
extensive examination of the life and
record of the Florida governor so then
they went on this little tweet thread
beneath it where they excerpt some of
the things in there and the first one
here I don't care if someone's gay Ron
DeSantis once said several years ago as
a 30-something Congressman I don't know
why people get caught up in that but as
Governor he has been an eager culture
Warrior now what's interesting of course
about this is that what they think
they're doing is slamming DeSantis there
because they think that people think
well wait a minute he used to not care
about gay but now he does because it
don't say gay but of course any of you
watching this know this and hopefully
most people the truth has somehow seeped
or leaked into most most people's brains
I hope to understand that the bill had
nothing to do with not saying gay it was
all about keeping private conversations
that shouldn't be happening between a
public employee and a kid making sure
that they don't remain private and that
parents know what their kids are
learning parents know who their care
kids are talking to about gender and
sexuality and all of these things so
DeSantis fought it it's not that he
cares about who is gay I know that he
does not he has met my husband David and
said hello and given him a chest bump
okay they sent us onesies for the babies
okay like these are good decent people
he wants everyone to be treated equally
this was all about transparency in
education but they try to frame it in
such a way that oh he used to not care
about gay but now he's a culture Warrior
going after the homos
it continues
they talk about Christopher rufo now so
you guys know rufo has been on the show
many times Christopher rupo a
conservative activist who has advised
DeSantis team told Matt Flagg Governor
DeSantis understands culture War as
public policy so again what they're
going to here is that DeSantis really is
just about the culture War which is an
extension somehow of trump it's some
it's something like this he doesn't
really care about economics he doesn't
really care about the things that matter
he care matters he cares about you know
he cares about and the gender stuff and
it's like yeah that is the stuff that
matters right now because it's actually
quite literally destroying the fabric of
the nation everything is being torn
apart by the culture War stuff and you
guys at the New York Times and at CNN
Etc you've owned the culture for so long
that what you're upset about now is that
in the culture war that you were winning
handily you are starting to lose so
again it's about the framing that they
have here here's a good one it continued
but Rhonda said says his caneest feat as
Shadow candidate has been dazzling
right-wing media types while heartening
party Elites who see him as one of their
own and then there's a quote here from a
republican operative and it says there's
a lot riding on trying to make Ron
DeSantis happen they see him as somebody
who gets them out of having to defend
trunk nut trunk now what's hilarious
about this this is a republican
operative her name is Sarah Longwell she
is a republican operative and publisher
of the anti-trump conservative the
bulwark so the bulwark is in business to
take down Trump not to defend
conservatism at any level but what
they're saying is there what they're
saying there is to sand his talks to
these online people and they're very
scary and really they're sort of in on
it too because they want to figure out a
way to get rid of trump of course they
talked about some of those people
specifically in the article I think
you'll recognize one of the guys
on and off camera DeSantis has forged
relationships not only with Fox where a
producer once gushed to a member of the
governor's staff that he could host the
show my God he talked to a producer at
Fox and they said he's talented but with
edgelord media types who have flocked
his State and boosted him online a
former aide told me DeSantis regularly
reads his Twitter mentions in January
invite he's to a dinner at the
governor's mansion included Dave Rubin a
popular right-wing web talk show host
and Benny Johnson a news max host fellow
DeSantis heads from the extremely online
right include Alex Jones who in August
declared him way better than Trump
before begging the former president for
forgiveness and Elon Musk with whom the
governor has died so there I am being
described can you put it up one more
time I along with Elon Musk and Benny
Johnson are being described as part of
the extremely online right I don't
really know what that means I'm also a
pop popular right wing web talk show
host well I suppose that is true to a
certain extent now it doesn't fit the
narrative so if you're just an average
person reading this article you might
read that and if you don't know me you
might go oh David Rubin David this Dave
Rubin must be some sort of right-wing
Maniac nothing about that he was a lefty
for most of his life nothing about that
he happens to be married to a dude
nothing about a fact that he wrote a
book defending Classical liberalism
nothing about a fact that he's uh
begrudgingly pro-choice
etc
etc but they want to frame everything in
these very scary ways and I should you
know now it's time for a mayakulpa it is
true that I had dinner at the governor's
mansion in January it is true and we had
filet mignon actually it was served
family style it was quite delicious I've
been meaning to get this off my chest
for a while and I should have told you
guys if nobody else
um I had a second piece of chocolate
cake at dinner it was a molten chocolate
cake with a little ice cream and it was
delicious I didn't ask the governor I
just went in and took it and uh so there
New York Times have at it you know I get
I'll get what I deserve I'll get my
comeuppance I suppose but this is what
they do with everything and this is what
they did for years and years with Trump
right like you let all the Democrats get
away with stuff but you figure out a way
to frame everything that now he's a
culture Warrior Who's online with scary
people and extremely online and
something about Alex Jones and blah blah
blah it's all just silly drivel for the
NPCs the non-playable characters these
people who cannot think and just accept
what the corporate press gives them but
I want to sort of drive that home with a
couple other things that are happening
at the moment uh the New York Times is
also going after Blake Masters Now Blake
Masters is the Republican running for
Senate in Arizona
and we've had them on the show I
consider Blake a friend he opened for me
on tour he's a good dude like he's just
a decent Silicon Valley dude he's not
he's not a traditional say religious
conservative or something like that he's
just a decent guy who wants Arizona to
have a border and you know protected
citizens and all those things so of
course the machine's going after him now
too in the same way they're going after
DeSantis because they got one move in
the Playbook and we just have to know
what the move is expose it show it to
people and move on uh before we get to
that let's talk about real estate agents
I trust you guys know that buying or
selling a home is already one of the
most stressful things you could do and
it can be 10 times worse if you're not
working with the right agent generally
speaking our homes are our biggest
investment which is a ton of
responsibility and you need an agent who
takes that seriously that's why I
recommend real estate agents I trust
they work with only the best agents in
every Market they do their homework
talking to every agent before inviting
them to join their Network and here's a
big one they only work with full-time
Pros no part-time or inexperienced
agents their team he makes the
introduction follows you through the
buying or selling process to make sure
that you're satisfied the ages they work
with have long track records they're the
best sellers in their field they're part
of this audience they share your values
and they're almost anywhere you want to
go just go to Real Estate
agentsitrust.com today give them some
basic info their team will contact you
to make an introduction to a preferred
agent in your town you move and you live
happily ever after Okay so let's kind of
continue with this theme that the
mainstream media picks the good guys and
bad guys and then they lie about who the
actual good guys are it is it is what
they have been doing for a long long
time it's not just Ron DeSantis with the
strange framing of these articles and
that really the whole point as I said
earlier was to drive a wedge what would
they want more than anything right now
if if let's say Trump and DeSantis are
the two most powerful Republicans two
most powerful conservatives in the
country and they for the most part agree
on most of the big issues I would say
their style is different they each have
different baggage and strengths and
weaknesses and styles but what but they
basically view America in a similar
frame so what would be the greatest
thing that could happen for the media or
for the Democrats uh well it's obvious
what that would be and that would be
that you would drive a wedge between
them you would have them fighting I
don't think they're going to fall for it
and as I've said I think they need to
have a sit down at Mar-A-Lago or perhaps
elsewhere because Marlo was probably
bugged maybe at the governor's mansion
although Biden's probably you know
bugging that too
anyway you guys get it well it's not
just DeSantis that they're going after
uh here is a piece this week in the New
York Times uh on Senate candidate Blake
Masters is this from a couple not this
week right uh sorry this is about a
month ago pushing an immigration
conspiracy theory while courting Latinos
Blake Masters a top candidate in
Arizona's Republican primary for the
Senate has accused Democrats of plotting
to import new voters that poses a
challenge in a state where a third of
the voters are Hispanic okay now that's
interesting framing there because Blake
does believe that in essence the
Democrats have this open border policy
or not protecting the borders so that
more and more people can flood into the
state into Arizona particularly is what
he's worried about the Texas of course
to our border states and basically
change the demographics of the state get
these people on the state Dole they all
get the government handouts and then who
do they thank for that they thank
Democrats so they believe that they will
ultimately become Democrats so Blake is
not saying anything that is actually
that controversial it's it's quite true
now it's against the New York Times
narrative but it is quite true here's
Blake defending himself against that
attack people agree with us on the
issues this far left you know the
greatest trick they ever pulled was
convincing the American public that they
represent more than like five percent of
people
we have the majority on our side most
people know we don't want to defund the
police that's the dumbest idea I've ever
heard right we need to fund the police
normal people know you need a border you
don't have a country without a border 75
of arizonans know you ought to have to
show an ID in order to vote right this
is common sense stuff here
but somehow everybody feels silenced
right and I get it as a candidate I go
out and I say we need voter ID okay and
then they call me a racist and they call
me a bigot and oh you just want to
suppress minority votes and you just got
to let that roll off your back right I
don't care what the left says so when
the New York Times calls me a hard right
nationalist for simply wanting a quarter
with zero illegal immigration I don't
care I wear that as a badge of honor
isn't that great when I always talk
about this idea of just like saying what
you mean cleanly and clearly and plainly
and not worrying about what they're
doing right you can expose it you can
you can explain to people hey here is
what they're doing here is why they're
doing it but here's what I actually
believe the guy is not a far right
extremist what they by far right
extremists they just mean anyone that's
not a progressive that's exactly what
they mean and he is just clearly taking
them on hey I do want a clean border hey
I do want to make sure that people are
here legally etc etc but Blake is under
a lot of attack from the mainstream
media because he is gaining momentum and
they certainly do not the corporate
press certainly does not want the
Republicans taking over the Senate uh
here is Blake going after the Democrats
for throwing a party while the economy
tanks we've got skyrocketing inflation
the stock market is on fire normal
Americans are losing their life savings
and you said it what do the Democrats do
they throw a party for themselves isn't
that nice the inflation reduction act
party uh it looked pretty lame to me but
I'm sure it was expensive it was
probably what like two or three times
more expensive than it would have been
this time last year uh but they don't
care because it's funded by the taxpayer
they're just going to keep taxing the
hell out of us and printing money and
this this delusional Elite they can't
manage their way out of a paper bag they
are so disconnected from the pain really
that normal people are feeling
I mean again it's true it's clean and
it's honest and it's true and yes the
Democrats were throwing a party for this
inflation reduction act which was really
an inflation increase act because we
just spent more money which we don't
have and thus we're going to pay
interest on that money or China will one
day say we own all of you because of
your moronic policies and the Democrats
basically have nothing but they know
that the media will always run cover for
them well Blake is running against Mark
Kelly Mark Kelly is the incumbent uh
Democrat senator in Arizona and this is
a really beautiful it's just a 10 second
video or so this is a really beautiful
moment because Mark Kelly has asked if
he if Biden's doing a good job and every
Democrat has a huge problem on their
hands right now because the average
person obviously knows that Biden is not
doing a good job right so the 81 million
people that voted for Biden huge percent
of the percentage of them let's say
voted for Biden because they did not
like Trump so they don't know how to
defend Biden right now because at the
end of the day at the end of the day
even if you're completely brainwashed by
the media and everything you do know
basic things in your life you do know
that when you go to the supermarket and
you see prices of food chicken and eggs
and everything else considerably higher
you can sort of link that to whoever the
president might be whether it's your guy
or the other guy if you see gas prices
up right if you try to order something
online and you see that it's taking
weeks and it didn't when the other guy
you can start piecing things together so
everyone in the Democrat Party has a
major problem right now because they
don't know how to defend this guy and as
I keep saying he's just dead man walking
because they're gonna get rid of him
they ushered him in or they brought him
in to usher in all this nonsense and
they're going to get rid of him when
they have the chance so here is Mark
Kelly trying to explain whether Biden's
doing a good job or not your thoughts on
his job has he done a good job do you
think hey you know I you know first of
all it's not
my job to give him a report card
I mean there's something sort of honest
about that in an odd way right so like
you got to kind of respect them in a
weird way it's like he didn't just be
like yes I love the guy he's doing great
Biden is amazing he actually did
something more honest which is that
like what are we gonna do
um this is sort of consistent with what
a few of them have done right like we
played the video a couple weeks back
when AOC was asked if she would support
him and she basically was like but she
does it with a lot of red lipstick and
people seem to like watching her a
little bit more than that guy but anyway
you get the point they have a big big
problem on their hands right now because
we know that at midterm elections the
incumbent party always gets crushed
right they always get crushed should
happen to trump it happened to Obama it
happened to George W bush it happened to
Reagan it is almost always what happens
there are very few uh very few times
that that does not happen so he's in a
lot of trouble when it comes to that but
then he's also in a lot of trouble
because there's just nothing really to
defend and speaking of that yesterday
the markets tanked I think lost around
1200 1200 points something like that
yeah absolutely tagged and Biden was
given a speech as the markets were
tanking and Fox News jumped in and
interrupted the president for years so
many of us have been trying to fix this
problem
but for Years big Pharma blocked
Medicare from negotiating lower drug
practices
all right I do not want to be a party
crasher but we interrupt this
celebration for a hard cold dose of
reality stocks tanking because inflation
is accelerating the very inflation that
the President says he's made great
progress addressing heralding his
inflation reduction act as the Boon for
the economy that we didn't see in a key
number out earlier today all right so
you see how insane this is they are
throwing a party at the White House for
the inflation reduction act as the
market is tanking the numbers are going
down not good as he is telling you what
we did by printing the money and putting
more money out there and
his dysregulated emotions and all of
that stuff just I mean it's just perfect
juxtaposition it's absolutely perfect uh
we've got some uh some data on inflation
actually uh this is from the New York
Post yesterday U.S inflation Rose by a
higher than expected 8.3 percent in
August despite falling gasoline prices
adding pressure on the Federal Reserve
as it decides whether to impose another
super size interest rate hike the August
reading of the labor Department's
Consumer Price Index a closely watched
watched measure of the cost of good and
services Rose 0.1 percent compared to
July surprising economists who had
expected a slight month over month
decline now first off you know it's even
funny the way the New York Post which is
pretty good even the way they frame that
I mean yes gas prices have gone down a
little bit but that's only because they
went up a crazy amount so that's what
they always do right it's like boy
you've destroyed everything and then
things got a little bit better oh my God
don't you see things got a little bit
better it's just absolutely spectacular
but anyway the point is
the economy is not in great shape we all
know it and I would prefer that it would
be what a refreshing day it would be to
come in here if we woke up tomorrow if I
woke up tomorrow morning and I'm doing
at 7 15 a.m and I'm going back and forth
on my text with Phoenix and we're trying
to put the show together and he's like
Dave you're not going to believe it I
was up a half hour earlier than you and
Biden fixed the whole thing it would be
refreshing I wouldn't even know what to
do with myself it would be quite lovely
but it ain't going to happen
unfortunately uh here's a little bit
more of the White House Party they
brought in James Taylor to inspire the
crowd
I
can find the scenery
I've seen sunny days
[Music]
I'm not even sure why we played that
other it just I kind of like James
Taylor actually and David's been playing
a lot of James Taylor for the baby and
my mom loves James Taylor hi Mom but
like there's just something sort of
depressing about the whole thing like
that's I've Seen Fire and Ice here and I
said the days they were never what what
are you people doing anyway then Nancy
Pelosi trotted out she had a couple
vodka tonics and then she got out there
put her eyebrows on and then she just
couldn't get the crowd as fired up as
she wanted kitchen table items for
America's Working Families Mr President
thank you for unifying and inspiring a
vision of a stronger
Fair safer future for all for our
children your extraordinary leadership
has made this glorious day possible
I that's an Applause line
[Applause]
people people that's where you're
supposed to applaud you're not supposed
to be sleeping when I'm talking later in
Her speech she referred to solar panels
it's kitchen table issues because that's
always what people are talking about
over at the kitchen table and then they
brought out old Joe and he just screamed
and rambled incoherently you just have
to remember who we are we are the United
States of America there is nothing
nothing we've ever set our mind to
nothing that we're not if we've not been
able to accomplish
nothing beyond our capacity
and to just remember who we are we stand
together there's nothing beyond our
capacity
may God bless you all and may God
protect our troops thank you thank you
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
just all of it the disregulated anger
which by the way is a symptom when you
have cognitive issues your emotional
regulation is not quite right and the
yelling and then picking his jacket up
off the floor like just the whole thing
it's just the Optics are just so bad but
here's black lesbian Karin Jean-Pierre
who is the White House Press Secretary
being asked if she's worried that
there's some distance between the party
the Democratic party uh they're
messaging on what's going on with the
economy and what's actually happening
while an Administration certainly has
the opportunity to celebrate
achievements like legislation is there
any concern that there's a dissonance
between the current economic moment and
the kind of Celebration you'll have this
afternoon on the south lawn about the
inflation reduction act when today's
figures show that inflation is still a
great concern when we've talked about
the Amtrak situation and so forth is
there a disconnect there so I think if
we look at the the picture more broadly
about what this means because we have to
remember the inflation reduction Act is
historic if you think about how um how
guys it doesn't really matter what's
happening this is historic what we're
doing here it doesn't matter if the
inflation reduction act actually
increased inflation we're doing
something historic guys and also it says
reduction in the title of the thing it's
the inflation reduction act do I have to
explain do we have to carry the one for
you people God anyway all this being
said I really you know I one of the
things that I really want to focus on
and that I thought about a lot in August
when I was off the grid is I don't want
to have blind spots on these things and
I don't want to be in an echo chamber
myself and I don't want you guys to be
in an echo chamber and I know that
that's extremely difficult these days it
really is when one side is calling you
fascists and bigots and Nazis it's hard
to kind of keep reaching out to them it
makes it very difficult so I tweeted out
something this morning because I really
believe this I would love to find some
Biden supporters true Biden supporters
to have on the show because we are told
he got 81 million votes so there's got
to be a whole bunch of people out there
who really support this guy so here's my
tweet from this morning and it got a
bunch of traction and I will keep
checking the responses throughout the
day I said I'd love to have an avid
Biden supporter on the show someone who
truly believes Joe Biden is mentally fit
and healthy that his policies on economy
covid immigration Etc are sound and that
he's moving America in the right
direction is there anyone so I saw
there's already a couple hundred
responses that on a quick lens I
couldn't really come up with anybody
like there I don't see anyone jumping at
it like a verified account that's really
saying it now we know that there are
certain media types that support him and
they're a Democrat just kind of democrat
operatives that's not who I'm talking
about I'm talking about like sort of
regular people uh I don't mean like just
the average Joe on the street but I'm
talking about people who know something
about politics who really think this
thing is working is they're an economist
who really thinks this working is there
anyone that really wants to defend him
on the covid policies and the mandates
and all of these things is there anyone
who really wants to go on the record and
say that they don't think there's
anything wrong with the guy
I'm willing to have this conversation I
I truly truly am now the problem is
they won't do that because they're so in
on it with him so here's a a lovely
compilation of left-wing media types
hyping Biden accomplishments and I I
we're going to play this one to the
backdrop of you guys know that when on
the blue moon on the rare occasion that
CNN or MSNBC says something honest we
try to play that right I'm always like
ah I guess we got to play this look even
they are saying something honest about
the economy but look at the boot licking
from these people about the Biden
Administration he actually has one big
thing is Biden's winning streak
President Biden has been racking up wins
racking up win after win this is a big
big win big victory at the White House
look at this huge accomplishment list of
accomplishments for Joe Biden uh just
seems to keep growing he's he's on a
roll it is a remarkable record it's all
moving in Joe Biden's Direction he's got
his aviators on inflation is you know
still a factor gas prices are actually
coming down and have been coming down
for almost 2 two months the inflation
rate is incredibly high but look at
those jobs numbers on Friday the
unemployment numbers are remarkable
inflation reduction act great name now
for all of those who say President Biden
what are you going to do about inflation
you've got it
that woman on MSNBC at the end that was
it
that joke that I made a minute ago she
just did the joke in real life
it says inflation reduction act in the
title when people ask you what he's
doing just tell him because he's in the
title it's incredible it's absolutely
incredible absolutely incredible how
else is it incredible it's not just that
they sort of lie or that they make nice
when things are not going well if they
like the guy they also ignore stories
when things are not going well so uh
Benjamin Shapiro Mr facts don't care
about your feelings over there at the
daily wire uh he had a great tweet
yesterday this is really spectacular so
Ben wrote the the Dow dropped 1200
points today and inflation exceeded
expectations so here's the Washington
Post current home page you've got
something about Ken Starr who died he
was the guy that was in charge of Bill
Clinton's impeachment uh you've got
something about Russia spending millions
and you've got something about Elon Musk
there so meaning that the front page as
the Dow is tumbling 1200 points it's a
lot of points a lot of people lost a lot
of money yesterday something like I
think it was over a trillion dollars or
something like a lot of money was wiped
out they don't cover that because that
would then have Washington Post readers
going boy is the administration doing
something wrong here is the inflation
reduction act not working and does the
word reduction not mean reduction what
could possibly be happening here instead
they just I'm not even saying that those
other stories aren't somewhat important
Ken Starr was was a relevant person 20
something years ago okay put it on page
two
do you think they would have covered the
inflation numbers if the numbers were
good for Biden I'm pretty pretty sure
that they would so so what's the problem
here it seems to me that the supposedly
the smartest and most educated people
the people who go to Harvard and Yale
who run our government and run our media
and our newspapers that they actually
get everything wrong and they don't have
real world experience and they will do
anything to hold on to power and to hold
on to the basic idea that they are
pretty much better than you but this
cannot work anymore it does not work
anymore and and it cannot continue any
longer because we see what happens when
they get power and when they defund the
police and when they take charge of the
economy and when they're in charge of
covid policy and all of those things
they actually literally make the quality
of your life worse so let's go back to
the beginning to the birthday boy
Governor Ron DeSanto this mocking the
people who have those useless college
degrees a lot of these students are
going to go through no debt and many of
them will be making six figures within
just a couple years the truck drivers
are making that immediately once they go
so let's just look to see where the
opportunities are and you're not any
worse than anybody else because you
didn't get a four-year degree in fact
think of all the people that had
four-year degree in Zombie studies with
a hundred thousand dollars in debt and
then they end up in a job they could add
at a high school you look at compare
someone that goes into electrical
they're making 75 80 grand then they're
making 100 Grand then they start their
own business in their mid-20s and they
start making you know really significant
income uh there those are good pathways
the point of that really is that there
are other ways you don't have to play
their game which is believe what they
tell you to believe go to the schools
that they tell you to go to get the jobs
that they want you to get there are all
sorts of other ways to do it and if you
do it outside of the system yeah the
system will not be kind to you but I
suspect you will find more meaning and
happiness and joy and be surrounded by
better people than these cartoonish
clowns uh stick around for a cold close
let me get some comments from the locals
Community mama bear says oh no Dave
Rubin is a right-wing cake eating
extremist too it was chocolate molten
you know when you get into that molten
cake and that warm gooey Center
Tony says Republicans out registering
Democrats 27-1 in Florida right now I'd
love to see some numbers backing that up
I mean I have referenced uh something
many many times which is that when
DeSantis came into office just a couple
years back there were something like 40
000 more Democrats than Republicans and
right now there are over 300
000 more Republicans than Democrats so
so the numbers are trending in in a good
way for this state which is very good uh
and Kathy says they are trying to make
the scientists into the next bad guy
yeah the move with DeSantis regardless
of whether he runs for president or not
the move will be he's actually worse
than Trump because he has all of Trump's
policies but he's competent right so the
thing with Trump was always like Trump
is evil and the policies are horrible
and he's a monster and Hitler but at
least there's some level of incompetence
there so he can't get everything that he
wants to done so they will just take the
next version of that right it's just
part two of the movie okay we got rid of
the bad guy the super villain for uh the
first movie but now the sequel has a guy
who learned from the evil Bad Guy the
orange man with the crazy hair he
learned and he surrounded himself with
even scarier people like right-wing
Maniac Dave Rubin
guys don't forget to like And subscribe
to all of our videos and especially
subscribe over at rumble.com Reuben
report where all of our live streams are
up part one and two of my interview with
Vivek Rama Swami who is a really
interesting VC guy trying to trying to
get some of this diversity woke nonsense
out of our boardrooms and our
corporations and figure out a way for
you as an investor to actually invest in
things that are not against your
interests uh those uh first two clips
are up right now and the full things up
already ad free at roomreport.locals.com
and now we're called close and I'll see
you tomorrow yeah I'm deadly Earnest
about this imagine being a mom or a dad
look at your child you know the needs an
incident very to live to live
and not having the money to pay for it
not a joke think about it think about
what you'd think about at the time
think about how you'd feel if you didn't
have the insurance and didn't have the
money
it's wrong it's not who we are and we're
going to fix that too
foreign